et si on commençait par la fin sur scène
samedi soir une quarantaine
d'adolescents fou de joie
trois classes de théâtre qui célèbrent
leur exploit avoir chacune réussi à
monter et présenter une pièce en quatre
jours seulement
retour au point de départ mercredi nous
sommes au collège de montréal une des
trois écoles qui participent au défi
extrême à dos une classe de secondaire 2
en concentration théâtre l'enseignante
va présenter au groupe le metteur en
scène invité jean stéphane roy
moi je fonctionne avec vous sur le
principe de la création collective
donc j'ai aucun texte de écrits d'
avance on part de vous du théâtre pas de
texte rappelons nous on est mercredi et
la pièce sera jouée devant public samedi
à chaque fois de metteur en scène
cherche de l'inspiration chez les élèves
est ce que vous savez ce qui regarde pas
mes parents ses méthodes de lepage
demandé aux comédiens d'apporter des
objets qui sont importants dans leur vie
simon parle d'un anneau on apprend qu'il
dit est diabétique et doit constamment
ce piquet pour vérifier son taux de
sucre dans le sang
quatorze fois par jour environ 14 une
pièce en quatre jours l'enseignante est
emballé par le projet je vois l'occasion
d'aller plus loin d'essayer dans un
environnement quand même bien encadré
dont ce qui fait que c'est quand même
rassurant pour tout le monde mais on
fonce on essaye le metteur en scène lui
rend dénote une journée de passer et
toujours pas de texte à ce moment c'est
toujours max archives on retrouve les
élèves deux jours plus tard vendredi
après midi à la maison des arts de laval
le soir la nuit jean stéphane roy alors
à imaginer des tableaux créés des textes
on jouera par exemple avec les peurs on
y parlera du diabète d'elodie moi depuis
que je suis toute petite je vis avec un
univers à l'intérieur de moi essayons ap
la première fois au fait que comme jose
moi aussi l'affirmé on dirait que ça
fait réagir juste pour mon diabète à moi
mais pour tous les autres problèmes de
la vie ce soit et santé ou moins
familiers n'importe quoi que à la place
de prendre ses négatifs sont essayé de
prendre sont positifs et d'essayer de
s'en sortir plus fort
le festival théâtre ados à laval a aussi
ce but de favoriser le développement des
jeunes par le théâtre convaincu que
faire de l'improvisation au faire du
théâtre c'est aussi développer l'estimé
de soi
développer la confiance en soi
développer le partage on est parti de
rien pendant des jeunes pièce demain les
amis si votre espace de jeu là ça
commence à être vrai les élèves voient
la scène pour la première fois quand
vous êtes ici que vous parlez la moitié
de votre voix sa voix haut elle se perd
dans les cintres ça veut dire qu'il faut
parler deux fois plus fort pour que ça
sera demain soir ils vont jouer ici même
devant public comme on présente un
exercice qui s'appelle cas graves tantôt
la pression monte d'un cran
au cours de sa mission d euros attention
hein c'est un climat il faut que tu
crées là ouais pas trouvé je trouve des
disques partout
[Musique]
souvent du g14 ans et j'aime la musique
francophone auquel il a mis à part ça
vous êtes vraiment nuire et c'est là que
j'ai compris tout tourne autour
d'experts et c'est là que j'ai compris
des illuminations tout ne l'oublient pas
la représentation c'est demain jeudi
avec un univers à l'intérieur de moi
annie simon il doit porter un anneau de
pouvoir parce que lui il est un feu mais
toujours il a hâte de jouer devant
public
ça apporte quelque chose ça donne que
snow bien ça ça encourage c'est c'est
vraiment le fun parce qu'ils supportent
une ia plots 2 et x
c'est comme si il nous tenait la main
ceux qui vont leur tenir la main et
entre dans la salle alors que dans la
loge le metteur en scène y va de ses
derniers encouragements
imaginez trois quatre jours on n'avait
absolument rien d'un spectacle de 20
minutes que tout le monde aime doit
entrer sur scène c'est l'heure de vérité
qui vraiment regarder les étoiles avec
tout mon coeur avec tout un homme notre
univers cage encore on peut imaginer
tout ce qu'on dit depuis les pics je
suis tout petit j'ai bien avec un
univers à l'intérieur de moi il cet
univers s'appelle dit abete
c'est ce qui fait ma peur m'a forcée qui
m'empêche de faire pitié ils ont réussi
sa vraie envie les fils saleh poulet et
tout a réussi pire on n'a pas fait
d'erreurs ça s'est vraiment bien passé
c'est faux ils font vraiment vraiment
vraiment je vais encore de me dire comme
aisée c'est mission accomplie pour le
metteur en scène vous aviez peur au
début en mon dieu oui j angoisses et
leurs hôtes jusqu'à tahiti goeulzin
monsieur sékou ce qu'on fait ça
soulageait
pas de prix à gagner mais quand même des
gagnants tous ces jeunes sortent grandis
de cette riche et intense expérience
théâtrale
[Applaudissements]